so Brian what brings you here tonight
see this Bollywood film and to you know
I have not seen I've been to my first
puppet for Bollywood and I have heard
that there's this new 3d thing being
used with it so I'm curious to see how
they do you know I'm curious I know it
hasn't been done before so our Hayek's I
say high expectations I look forward to
them doing well they should say so I
expect them to do really well with
tonight hopefully you so yeah so that's
all I am here to support Perry all right
what do you say to an actor that says
hey I just want to do the creative I'm
not a business person I you're a friend
of mine being I'm much more on the
creative side you have to be more
business oriented as they tell you and
it really does help to get that to get
that
that insight because just being creative
you can get there the lack of a better
expression really screwed on your
business side but I think you need a
business side in order to move your
creative side forward so I think they
need to go hand in hand and you gotta
concentrate on both and what do you do
to kind of get your mojo back because
vegan actors between LA is a really
really disheartening thing when you feel
maybe like you know what I'm ready to
leave LA what do you do to recharge
never wanted to leave LA maybe go home
for vacation for about three weeks but
go see a show go see a show jump back
into class revisit your favorite movie
do something or your favorite actor or
something where you just read read maybe
your favorite book just to get rien
spired because going to see it shows the
way to really do it because you can get
good seats because that stuff to see
their faces and to see what they do and
to its really reinvigorates you so go
see your show
appreciate it thank you thank you